[Music]
the 20th century was a period of great
Strife for many people across the world
under the rule of cruel and oppressive
leaders Nations suffered Wars famine and
Legacies of trauma that will continue to
last for generations to come
hi I'm rich Burnett for wondriam and in
this episode of perspectives four
historians discussed some of the most
notorious tyrants of the 20th century
and not just the ones you might think we
begin now with a brief look at how
dictators wind up in power
[Music]
how do we describe a democratically
elected government that then uses its
mandate to restrict liberal rights what
if a leader wins free and fair elections
but then uses that position of power to
impose censorship to truncate civil
liberties or to persecute an ethnic
minority and what if that leader all the
while remains popular or even gets
re-elected because of those very actions
these things aren't Democratic in one
sense of the word but if that's what the
majority wants what else is it
this isn't just a theoretical question a
lot of the world's most brutal
dictatorships now and historically are
illiberal democracies Vladimir Putin has
systematically dismantled what existed
of Russian democracy he jails dissidents
persecutes ethnic chachins and kills
journalists and yet he's remained
immensely popular
countries like Hungary turkey the
Philippines and Brazil have all elected
and sometimes re-elected leaders whose
policies are more reminiscent of fascist
dictatorships than democracy
and we sometimes forget that even the
Nazis in Germany in the 1930s came to
power through free and fair elections
and as an added twist we should remember
that e-liberal democracies often voice
their actions in the language of
democracy itself
Adolf Hitler wasn't violating the rights
of the German people he was protecting
them from communism and foreign
domination
and even when he invaded other countries
he often Justified his actions by
claiming that he was protecting the
ethnic Germans who lived there
according to Hitler himself the great
masses of the people will more easily
fall victims to a big lie than a small
one
and the biggest lie for Hitler was to
make his enemies think he was a
reasonable and restrained person a
moderate nationalist who was at heart a
man of peace and a hero for the Common
Man
we now know what a monstrous lie that
was but it's important to recognize that
Millions were deceived by it for a long
time
the idea of one leader changing
everything for a nation by the wave of
his hand was so appealing to a world
plagued by chaos and indecision
the Carnage of the first world war
followed by the financial boom and bust
of the 1920s had created
a sense of helplessness as if nothing
could be done to prevent another crisis
unless one powerful force was mobilized
to answer all emergencies and to replace
disorder with discipline
out of fear people wanted to be led by
someone who seemed filled with purpose
and confidence
at its modest level this was simply what
Franklin Roosevelt was offering
Americans in his presidency
but in its most dangerous forms it gave
the world Hitler Mussolini and Stalin
Stalin was preeminent as leader from
around 1929 to 1953 roughly a quarter
century
so an entire third of Soviet communism's
74-year history was dominated by one man
yet Stalin somehow remains less firmly
fixed in historical memory for Americans
than Hitler who for us is the epitome of
the Tyrant leader an icon of evil
it's estimated that Stalin was
responsible for the deaths of some 10 to
20 million while some estimates go far
higher than that
Stalin is supposed to have said one
death is a tragedy a million is a
statistic
yet his record is less known than it
deserves to be because he was an ally of
the United States during World War II
presented in propaganda as Uncle Joe a
down-to-earth honest leader of the
Soviet Union
some historians have preferred to think
of Stalin as a distorter of Lenin's
project with Lenin merely a socialist in
a hurry but we need to take into account
that Lenin promoted Stalin and Lenin
first created the organs that Stalin
later used expanded and perfected the
concentration camps secret police an
exemplary use of revolutionary Terror
in fact in his magisterial Tome the main
currents of Marxism Lesha kovakovsky
argues that the Soviet system as it
developed under Stalin was a
continuation of leninism and that the
state founded on Lenin's political and
ideological principles could only have
maintained itself in a stalinist form in
Fall 1929 Stalin demanded forced
collectivization he declared that now
the state was moving decisively against
its class enemies the so-called kulaks
that is modestly more prosperous
peasants
now there was to be a policy of
liquidating the rich peasants as a class
hundreds of thousands of kulaks were
arrested and deported the Red Army and
tens of thousands of volunteer activists
went to the countryside to conduct class
Warfare
agricultural production plummeted due to
Peasant resistance not only did farmers
lose incentive to plant grain they
slaughtered livestock and burned crops
rather than simply turning them over to
the authorities
in view of the resulting chaos in March
1930 Stalin called a halt blaming local
officials for extreme actions as a
result of being dizzy with success but
by Year's End Stalin resumed the drive
the imperative of control was just too
strong
food became state property and a 1932
law provided the death penalty for theft
of food
in Ukraine collectivization policies
caused the terror Famine of
1932-1933 remembered by ukrainians as
the holodomor or hunger killing
Soviet troops seized grain from areas
where hunger already threatened and
closed off territories where resistance
arose
in our own times of historical Amnesia
we must be very clear about this this
was not a natural disaster caused by
climate or drought or a bad Harvest
this was a political famine engineered
in one of the world's most productive
agricultural areas
estimates suggest that 5 million to 7
million people starve to death in
Ukraine famine also struck elsewhere
like the north Caucasus in Kazakhstan
the Soviet government denied reports of
the event
Stalin is said to have later casually
admitted to Churchill that 10 million
died
on October 1st 1949 Mao seitung stood
Atop The Gate of heavenly peace in
beijing's Tiananmen Square
behind him was the Forbidden City The
Spot from which the Chinese Emperors of
the Ming and Qing dynasties had ruled
China for centuries
declaring victory over the recently
exiled Chiang Kai-shek and his guoman
dung nationalist in a civil war that had
enveloped China for more than two
decades Mao announced that China would
now be led by a people's Democratic
dictatorship it would be based upon an
alliance between Chinese workers and
peasants
the era of communist China had begun
in its founding documents the People's
Republic of China balanced a commitment
to the freedoms of thought speech
assembly and the Press
with a vow to suppress all
counter-revolutionary activities
loyalty to the country became synonymous
with the active support of the
Revolutionary ideals as stipulated by
the ruling Cadre
now when so far as to Define his regime
as a people's Democratic dictatorship
full inclusion in the polity was
bestowed only on those whose lifestyle
and philosophy coincided with what the
ruling Communist Party deemed
appropriate
increasingly as we'll see one man Mao
Zedong defined and judged what was
acceptable
as for reactionary elements they were
deprived of political rights and
punished severely though they were also
given the opportunity to reform
themselves through physical labor
the new communist regime targeted class
enemies through a rectification campaign
that required citizens to publicly
confess to their ideological failings
and self-doubts
those deemed insufficiently contrite
found their way to newly established
labor camps
but Mao had to contend with external as
well as internal challenges
the Korean Peninsula divided between a
communist North occupied by Soviet
forces and a capitalist South occupied
by American troops erupted in Civil War
in June 1950 as North invaded South
four months later in October 1950
Chinese forces entered the conflict
thereby bringing the country into
confrontation with a U.S led United
Nations Force at the same time more than
700 000 Chinese were labeled as
counter-revolutionaries and executed
between 1950 and 1952 according to
official statements
this created a model to militarize the
revolution with clear linkages between
patriotism and Revolution that would
continue to define the People's Republic
Mao continued to consolidate the power
and authority of the communist regime
because he was about to embark on a new
stage of socialist Construction in the
country
in 1957 he announced the Great Leap
Forward a plan to speed up
industrialization
the state had only recently organized
peasants on large Collective Farms
called people's communes in an effort to
streamline and increase economic
production
now Mao announced that the communes
would shift from agriculture to steel
production
the goal was for China to double its
steel output in one year
aided by the labor of 100 million
peasants pulled away from farming
lacking Financial Capital the Communist
Regime marshaled human capital
all Chinese were called on to do their
part
predictably the outcome was a disaster
on agricultural communes around the
country backyard blast furnaces arose
rural workers were required to melt any
metal objects they could get their hands
on
propaganda posters depicted idyllic
scenes of agricultural communes churning
out ample food while in the background
furnaces efficiently produce the steel
needed for modernization
but crops were left to rot
and the communal dining Halls set up to
feed the people soon struggled to find
food
while the government censored news of
the famine
Scholars estimate that between 15
million and 45 million Chinese died
the man-made famine that resulted from
Mao's Great Leap Forward was one of the
deadliest in world history
some dictators are installed in office
not by their predecessors but by a
foreign power
installing a puppet regime is a
convenient way for a powerful country to
maintain influence over its neighbors
this method of succession was
particularly evident during the Cold War
when the United States and the Soviet
Union both sponsored coups and propped
up authoritarians in their respective
spheres of influence
of course neither was very loyal to its
own ideology when it did so the Soviet
Union for all its talk about empowering
workers and standing up for the poor
propped up any number of outright
kleptocracies and the United States for
all its rhetoric about spreading
democracy installed some very brutal
dictatorships it has been said that what
was crafted in North Korea is the most
extreme example of Personality cult on
record it centers on the Kim family
which has so far provided a succession
of three semi-divine leaders from 1948
to the time of this presentation in 2021
73 years consider that the Bolsheviks
were in power for 74 years the Soviet
Union lasted for 69 years
the first leader was Kim al-son known as
the great leader installed by Soviet
forces
at first Kim enjoyed support from both
the Soviet Union and China but when
their split grew he balanced between
them in subtle shifting ways
incidentally establishing a pattern that
endures in international politics to the
present day
more purges against party factions
aligned closely with Beijing or Moscow
kept Kim as the essential balancer
as in the cases of Albanian Romania this
amounted to an especially intense
assertion of national communism as a
trend
to underline this assertion of
Independence and a Korean form of
Communism Kim il-sung crafted the
ideology he called chuche or
self-reliance pursuing atarchy and
radical isolation
the four Central principles of chuche
were defined as autonomy and ideology
Independence and politics
self-sufficiency in economics and
self-reliance in defense
in practice it has also meant isolation
with rigidly controlled relations to the
outside world ordinary people have no
access to outside media a high degree of
Conformity is mandatory every household
is outfitted with a radio receiver the
speaker which broadcasts marches songs
and proclamations speakers cannot be
turned off or stations changed the
streets of towns and cities have blaring
loudspeakers for official announcements
settlements feature special study rooms
dedicated to the leader and chuchi
thought and one needs to wear special
socks to enter these study rooms
highlighting their almost religious Aura
of veneration adopted from Mao's China
the self-criticism ritual features
prominently in social life
being contrite about failings and
pledging to correct them is a sign of
continuing loyalty pledged again and
again those who did not obey Authority
and conform would be sent to
concentration camps along with their
extended families ostensibly to be
re-educated through hard labor and
suffering a dozen prison camps
resembling the Soviet Gulag were
established holding up to an estimated
million the inmates were subjected to
Awful abuse life inside the country was
truly terrible for ordinary Koreans
the economy suffered especially when the
Soviet Union's Aid and support was
removed with its unexpected collapse in
1991. Chinese Aid also was replaced by
more challenging Market relationships
agriculture had been neglected in favor
of planned progress in heavy industry
and supporting the vast military
structure of the state
in the 1990s famine gripped North Korea
ordinary people's diets shrank while
party cadres and Military Elites were
better supplied and spared the hunger
while it may have killed 3 million or 10
percent of the population it also left a
so-called stunted generation of children
journalists from National Geographic who
were allowed to make a rare trip to the
country afterward estimated that 40
percent of children showed signs of
chronic malnutrition
so for instance the incidence of
cataracts in North Korea was 10 times
higher than in the developed world not
only for the elderly but also for the
Young
in North Korea seven-year-old boys are
eight inches shorter than in South Korea
and 22 pounds lighter the generational
Damage Done by the famine will be
enduring
still dictatorship remains popular for
millions of people around the world it's
not just a viable option but a
preferable one
dictators don't have to worry about
elections and that means they can
undertake ambitious but costly projects
that might result in their country's
long-term good and they have
unparalleled capacity to muster the
resources of the state in no small part
because they don't have to worry about
pesky little things like human rights
finally authoritarian regimes don't have
to put up with nearly as much gridlock
or dysfunction as democracies do and the
more the world's democracies flounder
the more the world's people might end up
casting their votes in favor of
dictatorship
indeed the occasional popularity of
authoritarian regimes can make it hard
to distinguish between democracy and
dictatorship how do you define a regime
that doesn't hold elections but would
win them if it did
how do you define a regime that wins
elections fairly but then uses its power
to violate human rights or to persecute
ethnic and religious minorities
all of these things make it hard not
just to determine the survivability of
dictatorship but to define it
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria